[Música]
se extinguirá el ser humano
si se extingue
será dentro de mucho lo verán mis nietos
mis bisnietos será dentro de cien años
será dentro de doscientos años o tal vez
nunca suceda
eso son algunas cosas que suelen
preguntarme cuando veo escenas como la
de esa foto que tomé en una playa de
uruguay hace pocos días
tal vez
dentro de 10.000 años alguien baja por
allí vi lo que ve como restos de la
civilización que estuvo es algo así
cuál será el animal que tenga un cerebro
más inteligente en ese entonces si
nosotros no estuviéramos
esta imagen también evoca para mí este
disco que conocí cuando tenía 15 años
que se llama cerca del abismo
close to the edge en su título original
era la música que escuchábamos al
comienzo una música tal vez un poco
enojada porque creo que debe enojarnos
un poco ver imágenes como esta
este es el disco
que lo conocí cuando tenía 15 años
pasaba mi verano jugando al fútbol en
una plaza horas y horas en la tarde
mientras julio uno de los amigos del
barrio no jugaba el fútbol tocaba la
flauta al borde de la cancha y trataba
de sacar una melodía que le resultaba
muy trabajosa un día le pregunté qué era
lo que estaba tocando y me dijo oye
total
yo no sabía quererse trotar le pregunté
que era tratar me dijo el rock
progresivo no creo que te vaya a gustar
no son canciones de tres minutos para
que pasen en la radio es música y la
música dura lo que tenga que durar si
dura 20 minutos que dure le pedí que me
diera el disco que para él era más
importante de ese desarrollo progresivo
y me obsequió este disco escuché el
comienzo del disco que ustedes acaban de
escuchar y me resultó incómoda la música
y dije efectivamente como me dijo un
amigo julio esta música a mí no me van
bueno me gusta me resulta chocante y
cuando fui a guardar el disco se me cayó
y se rompió una partecita de modo que le
compré un disco nuevo y me quedé con el
disco ruth dude tirarlo o no pero decidí
con conservarlo
y días después cerca de empezar las
clases escuché el disco entero y me
pareció atrapante no me había gustado
del todo pero me parecía intrigante
cuando empezaron las clases al lado mío
se sentó un compañero nuevo que no
conocía gabriel
y los dos teníamos creo la misma
rebeldía contra ese liceo gris que se
preocupaba de que nuestro pelo no
llegara al cuello de la camisa o que no
cubriera ni un poquito de la oreja
tiempos de dictadura
y pasados unos días le pregunté si
conocía y es y me dijo claro cerca del
abismo
una obra maestra pero de qué va eso mi
hijo y bueno básicamente vamos rumbo
hasta hacia nuestra propia
autodestrucción estamos siendo
arrastrados hacia nuestra propia
autodestrucción
pero de qué manera bella lo cuenta jon
anderson diciendo me levanto pero me
vuelvo a caer y me vuelvo a levantar
pero me vuelvo a caer y me voy yendo
hacia ese abismo era bello y dramático a
la vez veníamos de un mundo verde pero
hoy vamos hacia un futuro negro la banda
ya había tocado ese tema en el disco
anterior luego lo supe
y mostraba en este disco en su edición
original también luego lo supe esa
imagen de una catarata vamos siendo
arrastrados hacia un punto en el que ya
no habrá retorno donde la correntada
será tan fuerte que por más que nos
venga la desesperación no podremos ir
marcha atrás
antes habían hecho ese disco frágil
un mundo bello pero muy frágil que
podría eventualmente estallar en mil
pedazos y tal vez la única esperanza
sería subirse una nave a tratar de
encontrar otro mundo habitable cuál es
la corriente que tal vez podríamos decir
nos está llevando hacia un abismo
podrían ser varias
pero básicamente esa gráfica me parece
que representa una de las principales
gráficas que tenemos para ver es la
medida del dióxido de carbono en el aire
en uno de los lugares más prístinos del
mundo en una montaña en hawai
malova
veníamos de un mundo con menos de 300
partes por millón
en el siglo 19 posiblemente y hemos
cruzado las 400 partes por millón y esta
gráfica no muestra ninguna señal de caer
la tendencia que es lo que se ve en la
línea negra por ahora sigue subiendo
quemamos petróleo quemamos carbón
y entonces nos vamos intoxicando
gradualmente podríamos decir pero
ustedes verán que tiene oscilaciones son
interesantes y esas oscilaciones si
miramos la gráfica en el detalle de
dónde estamos y dónde se proyecta que
vaya esa gráfica se proyecta que siga
creciendo naturalmente pero porque esa
oscilación porque sube y porque baja
porque resulta que en el hemisferio
norte donde están la mayoría de las
plantas porque dónde está la mayoría de
la superficie de tierra firme cuando las
plantas brotan en primavera y verano
sacan carbono de la atmósfera y bajamos
circunstancialmente pero luego cuando
llega el otoño y el invierno el carbono
vuelve a subir en cierta manera es como
si fuera la respiración del planeta lo
que percibimos allí y en cierta manera
es bello que las plantas brotando nos
ayuden sacando circunstancialmente
durante seis meses de ese carbón
el resultado de esa gráfica el resultado
de que tengamos cada vez más gases en la
atmósfera es el aumento de la
temperatura del planeta
aquí en uruguay algo percibimos un
aumento de cerca de un grado pero es muy
grave lo que sucede cerca del polo norte
donde la temperatura se ha disparado 45
grados por arriba de lo normal
eso es hielo que se derrite y eso es muy
grave
esta es la evolución de la temperatura
tomando como un cero la temperatura
normal del siglo 19
no pasó gran cosa al comienzo del siglo
20 pero en la segunda mitad del siglo 20
la trayectoria es clara y los últimos
cuatro años
fueron los cuatro más cálidos por lejos
desde que hay registros
los meteorólogos nos advierten que no
debemos cruzar el 1.5 pero ya hemos
cruzado el 1° de diferencia puede ser
que un grado nos parezca que no es mucha
diferencia si tenemos un grado de fiebre
no nos sentimos bien pero esto es muy
diferente a la fiebre que sentimos
nosotros que con una pastilla o
esperando que se vaya vuelve a la
temperatura normal es muy diferente
podríamos decir que la ley alarmante del
calentamiento global es que a más
calentamiento más calentamiento es un
circuito que se alimenta a sí mismo
porque el calentamiento por ejemplo
genera incendios que son una gran
liberación de calor es a esos árboles
que acumularon carbono y a través de la
energía solar durante años en segundos
liberan toda esa energía
porque cuando se derrite el polo
ese hielo blanco que reflejaba la luz
solar deja de reflejar la y esa luz
solar entra en el oscuro océano y
calienta las aguas en vez de rebotar
porque otras zonas terrestres que tenían
hielo se derriten y ahí se libera
muchísimo metano que es un gas que
también calienta la atmósfera aún más
que el dióxido de carbono porque se
generan más fenómenos climáticos
extremos que implican más erosión y más
erosión además del daño que es sobre el
suelo implica también más liberación de
gases a la atmósfera y en definitiva
porque generan más de certificación más
crisis social y a gente que está
padeciendo una crisis social no se le
pueden plantar problemas climáticos a
2030 ó 50 años de modo que cuanto más
fiebre tenemos más velozmente podemos
seguir aumentando la temperatura
y si miramos las noticias tenemos
razones para preocuparnos a qué
distancia está ese punto de no retorno a
qué distancia está ese momento en el que
por más que hagamos lo que hagamos el
calentamiento seguirá hay quienes dicen
que está tan solo a 12 años de distancia
en términos evolutivos eso es nada y en
términos de hacer cambios sociales es
muy poco tiempo y está bien ilustrado
esto esto fue en australia hubo
incendios tremendos este verano
australia llegó cerca de los 50 grados
este verano
i
también los océanos como decíamos se
calientan rápidamente y esto genera
otros efectos encadenados además de la
gran pérdida de biodiversidad porque los
océanos se calientan y se vuelven cada
vez más ácidos el ph del agua va bajando
y si tuviéramos una pecera y el y el
agua de nuestra pecera se fuera haciendo
cada vez más ácida sabríamos que en
algún momento los peces mueren de golpe
seguramente todos
entonces posiblemente nuestras vidas
están por tener cambios muy fuertes pero
que en el día a día los dejamos para
otro momento que solidaridad
intergeneracional estamos teniendo
el hielo del casquete polar norte se
está derritiendo cada vez más velozmente
eso genera otro riesgo que es que el
nivel del mar de un súbito aumento podrá
haber una equis aquí dentro de 100 años
un grupo de científicos que reúne a 15
premios nobeles de la universidad de
chicago ha diseñado un reloj para
hacernos ver más gráficamente a qué
distancia estamos de un colapso
generalizado como civilización y los
últimos años no son para nada
alentadores esto surgió luego de la
segunda guerra mundial vinculado a la
amenaza de guerra nuclear pero ha sumado
el cambio climático allí y si la
medianoche fuera el colapso venimos de
tres minutos en 2015 y 2016 a dos
minutos y medio en 2017 a dos minutos en
2018 aunque los minutos sean una
metáfora es una metáfora fuerte y es
algo que tiene un respaldo académico
también fuerte por detrás
el futuro posible
quién sabe con qué probabilidad es una
tierra que finalmente se nos vuelva
inhabitable nuestra soberbia de creer
que la tecnología lo resolverá todo
mágicamente nos puede jugar una mala
pasada es muy difícil de resolver esto
porque tal vez en parte a partir de los
trabajos de richard o kings sobre las
bases
evolutivas de nuestra conducta no
estamos programados para pensar el 50 o
el 80 o en 100 años para adelante
estamos pensados estamos programados
para pensar en el corto plazo en cuál va
a ser mi próximo empleo en cuál va a ser
mi pareja
en cómo voy a mejorar este año y el año
que viene pero no en los problemas que
tendrán nuestros nietos o nuestros
bisnietos
entonces
es necesario salir de una zona de
confort pero que no nos resulta fácil el
simple hecho de fumar y tirar un pucho a
la vereda
un plástico que terminará en el mar que
terminará en el cuerpo de un pez y que
será un montón de micro plásticos es de
las cosas más dañinas que hay pero
decirle un fumador que se guarde su
pucho hasta que encuentre un lugar donde
tirarlo parece algo muy difícil de
lograr a la luz de cuántos filtros
encontramos en las veredas
y eso tiene una consecuencia muy grave
que es que políticamente este tema nos
sirve para ganar votos y tenemos al
principal país emisor de gases de efecto
invernadero con un presidente que niega
que este problema existe y tenemos al
país que tiene la mayor cantidad de
amazonia con un presidente que promete
talar amazonia para generar más
crecimiento económico y más empleo
también el arte me ha inspirado para
darme un cierto toque de esperanza
porque en definitiva podemos conversar
de este tema y tenemos a la ciencia que
es la gran herramienta que tenemos para
chequear qué es lo que está pasando y
cómo solucionarlo y brian eno me parece
un músico muy importante y un pensador
muy importante con una fundación que se
llama the long now fundation el presente
largo
que he hecho un reloj que está
programado para funcionar durante diez
mil años sin romperse estaremos dentro
de diez mil años este disco que me
parece imperdible se llama antes y
después de la ciencia y creo que sobre
el pensamiento científico puede
salvarnos y puede ayudarnos a construir
lo que muestra otro disco de brian en lo
que se llama otro mundo verde con esa
imagen tal vez llamando a un nuevo
renacimiento una nueva iluminación en
todo caso no hablan específicamente de
cambio climático pero recomiendo
escucharlos entonces quizás es tiempo de
hacer algo porque seguirá siendo todo
como hasta ahora parece llevarnos por un
mal camino y me parece que es algo
interesante en momentos en que a veces
la gente dice bueno cuál es el propósito
de vivir se han terminado las las
grandes ideologías se ha terminado la
ilusión de paraísos o de infiernos y tal
vez un propósito que se puede proponer
es alejar a las generaciones que vienen
de ese peligro que no sabemos cuán
inminente es y que tiene componentes que
son muy agradables porque las plantas
son nuestras aliadas y creo que ver
crecer una planta es algo que a todos
bastante placer cuando vemos en la
planta a veces vemos un mero objeto
decorativo en realidad esa planta lo que
está haciendo es captando energía solar
y está captando dióxido de carbono como
mostraba es aquella gráfica y está
liberando oxígeno que es lo que
precisamos para respirar en cada momento
está generando tal vez alimento para
nosotros o para un herbívoro entonces
las plantas son nuestras grandes aliadas
cuando vemos una hoja lo que vemos es el
gran primer panel solar que inventó la
evolución en cierta manera podríamos
pensar
un poco ingenuamente que la solución
está en la palma de nuestra mano
tal vez podemos convocar a cubrir de
plantas a las ciudades
debemos ver eso en las plantas paneles
solares capturadores de carbono
liberadores de oxígeno
nuestra ganadería la ganadería en
general está siendo muy cuestionada un
vacuno emite 200 litros cada día de
metano eso es un problema pero en el
caso de la ganadería de uruguay es una
ganadería que es guardiana de las
últimas praderas que quedan naturales
del hemisferio sur
y es una buena imagen una pradera
natural con energía eólica ese es el
camino de la ganadería en contraste con
las ganaderías que talan selva y generan
realmente una situación caótica en zonas
más tropicales bastaría con cultivar
plantas sería tan simple como decir
tengamos más plantas hagamos bueno de la
botánica nuestra salvación no
lamentablemente creo que la solución es
más grave y más compleja que es entonces
hay un montón de cosas que están todas
relacionadas
el hecho de comportar no dejar la basura
entreverada lo orgánico con la bolsa de
nylon el reclamar más espacio para
bicicletas en reclamar una más veloz
conversión hacia vehículos eléctricos
en la agronomía el ir hacia pastoreo más
racional es a una agricultura más
responsable con capacidad de fijar el
carbono porque fijar carbono además es
aumentar la fertilidad de los suelos
suspender toda tala de selva reforestar
donde se pueda reforestar
tal vez
estas tecnologías que avanza tan veloz
nos proporciona una máquina que quita el
co2 el dióxido de carbono del aire pero
jugarnos a esa invención mágica es muy
arriesgado cuando lograremos que esa
botella que estaba el comienzo de la
presentación se debió plástico y que una
lombriz pueda devorar la y convertirla
en humus
colocar ese carbono bajo tierra en
nuestra ropa
vamos a usar fibras derivadas de
petróleo vamos a usar fibras naturales
compostables
la energía tiene que cambiar tenemos que
lograr superar el petróleo tenemos que
lograr entrar en una era post petróleo
lo antes posible puede ser hidráulica
eólica solar tal vez nuclear
en fin
tal vez la bioconstrucción también la
producción local que implica un menor
transporte es decir lo que precisamos es
una ofensiva en múltiples direcciones
para revertir tendencias que nos ponen
en un grave peligro y debemos actuar en
europa están surgiendo movimientos
sociales nuevos en particular este
proclama que nos rebelamos respecto al
status quo o nos rebelamos respecto a
como el sistema político está tomando
este tema o lo que nos espera es la
extinción y su símbolo es un reloj de
arena porque el tiempo se va terminando
y hay una rebelión también de niñas y
adolescentes
que en europa están dejando de ir a
clase los viernes para ir a
manifestaciones porque saben que el
planeta que le estamos dejando es un
planeta tremendamente frágil no hay un
planeta ve dice esta niña de bélgica
lo cierto es que naciones unidas nos
dice que somos la última generación que
puede frenar el cambio climático si no
lo hace esta generación
posiblemente los niños de hoy ya será
demasiado tarde
y tal vez la mayor amenaza que tiene el
planeta es que todos pensemos que
alguien de alguna manera sin que
nosotros hagamos nada le encontrara una
solución
entonces creo que este es un tema
interesante también en búsqueda de un
consenso global es tal vez la primera
guerra entre comillas que podemos
disputar todos los seres humanos pero no
contra otros seres humanos sino una
guerra por restaurar el desorden que
hemos hecho en estos últimos 200 años
tal vez podemos superar las dicotomías
de izquierda contra derecha o de
creyentes contra no creyentes y
encontrar un consenso que le dé un
sentido a lo que hacemos a lo que
reclamamos a los gobiernos pero también
a lo que hacemos en nuestra vida
cotidiana y en realidad hay una
corriente cada vez más fuerte de si
hacemos alimentos hacerlos con un
propósito si hacemos textiles hacerlos
con un propósito en realidad lo que
hacemos hacerlos con ese gran propósito
de construir una sustentabilidad que
tenemos casi perdida
caeremos en el abismo siguiendo siendo
todo igual o lograremos revertirlo eso
hace casi 50 años proponía este disco
que está aquí
aún en las condiciones más difíciles una
planta logra crecer capturar energía
solar y construir carbono tenemos una
esperanza muy pequeña pero es lo que
tenemos tal vez los sex pistols tienen
razón y ya no tenemos un futuro pero tal
vez si tenemos un futuro y estamos a
tiempo de revertirlo bob dylan diría que
lo que pase respecto a lo que pase al
tamaño de nuestra esperanza
la respuesta está flotando en el viento
en este caso literalmente muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]